Хтось має бути лідером маяком Вона каже
Я буду лідером Молодець Як її батько
молодець за неньку Україну от вона пото
в неї очі горять я буду так як батько я
буду військовою буду чице помста буде
Потім це підготовка до комста усі ці
слова про мотивацію Ярослави журавель їй
15 змалку Вона мріяла стати професійною
спортсменкою втім війна Росії проти
України змінила її життя У дитячому віці
і змусила шукати шляхи помсти за смерті
рідного батька на фронті у військовій
справі зброя положилась магазин
положився і в такому положенні чекає до
мішені
підняли і побігли до
мішені під час вогневої підготовки
Ярослава журовель хвалиться відмінними
результатами дев'ять влучань у мішень з
10ти Це її улюблена частина тренувань на
полігоні зівзву водом разом з іншими
вихованцями Київського військового ліцею
імені Богуна Вона навчається задля мети
Одного дня стати дола в ЗСУ поначалу так
переживала Адреналін а потім уже як
стріляла то так
сподумалось я хотіла бути як тато піти
по його стопам Тато був
розвідником в Морськой піхоті Ну
спочатку в 20-й мпб потім в 93-й
з 2014 року батько дівчини Ярослав
журавель служив у зоні поблизу
окупованих Луганщини та Донеччини про
свою службу Він не міг розповідати
багато втім донька захоплювалася місією
батька Я пам'ятаю його веселим
е добрим сильним і сміливим ми абограли
в якісь ігри по типу футболу Або я ще
тоді ходила на кікбоксинг він до мене
приходив в зал дивися як я
займалась Він завжди мене підтримав коли
там
на
соревнування липень 2020 року Ярослава
очікувала тата з фронту за день до свого
дня народження 13тиріччя вона дізналася
про його
смерть від поранення під час завдання
під зайцевим на Донеччині він кров'ю не
діставшись сірої зони до позиції
побратимів про ці події Ярослава не може
говорити І
донині коли були зроблені ці світлини з
дня поховання Ярослава вже знала вона
хоче продовжити справу батька того ж
року Вона чемпіонка України з
кікбоксингу залишила професійний спорт і
вступила до військового ліцею у свої
у нас в кожному взводі по три дівчинки
вони молодці пробіжали найкраще Ярослава
одна з перших прибігає під час
випробувань керівник ліцею генерал-майор
Ігор Гордійчук запевняє дівчина прийшла
до закладу Відмінно підготовленою на
свій вік тож зараз належить до
спортивної спецгрупи вона в першому
зводі спортивний зводу вони будуть
показувати приклад майстер-клас Хтось
має бути лідером маяком Вона каже Я буду
лідером Молодець Як її батько молодець
саме Рага до боротьби до до до це до до
цих ідеалів Євромайдану революції
гідності щоб ми в НАТО в Європі йшло і в
тому числі і помст заненьку Україну от
вона пото в неї очі горять основне що ми
бачимо в нашій аптечці - це турнікет
накладає максимально високо на ногу
фіксуємо це затягуємо максимально сильно
практичні заняття в ліцеї Ярослава дуже
цінує під час перших місяців
повномасштабної війни дівчині довелося
евакуюватися з Києва тож навчання було
дистанційним в той час Ярослава та її
дідусь постійно були на зв'язку з
побратимами батька так вони вирішили
разом бути корисними для ЗСУ як
волонтери Доброго
дня Слава
Україні у перерві між тренуваннями
Ярослави дідусь приїхав навідати онуку і
обговорити чергову допомогу для
української армії благодійний аукціон я
буду навчаться одновременно помагать там
якось
дистанційно А ми хочем відкрить
аукціон виставить
білети клички бо в нас папа дуже хотів
побачити з ними і бубуть у них на боях
щоб приїхав Кличко розписався на білет і
виставить і допомогу за зас То це в неї
такі плани мрії плани цілі вона до цього
йтиме це нація це гени в них уже
заложена ц оборона в них заложена Ця
країна в них воно вже в серці в місках
кругом що за життя оцієї країни за цвіту
цього дерева за цвіту тієї троянди
отдані життя життя батьків братів дідів
Дідусь та Онука регулярно збирають кошти
на одяг їжу та спорядження для ЗСУ А
цього літа Ярослава здійснила два
заповітних бажання відремонтувати старе
батькове авто та пере ти його воїнам
особисто на Донеччині усе це в пам'ять
про батька та інших полеглих героїв
мамоїх пам'ятати тому що
вони за нашу свободу положили своє життя
І це все що ми можемо робити щоб
пам'ятати про них мрія служити в ЗСУ і
волонтерство врятували Ярославу Від
прірви горя в якій Вона опинилася у
Перші роки після втрати тата- каже
дідусь дівчин
почались процеси дуже погані
на на базі цієї психіки всього на
обличчі неї стало повертати обличчя і з
мамою поїхала на реабілітацію в
Болгарію на цей час уже було заборонено
заніматься
спортом Ну в общем після реабілітації
Вона повернулась і вона чітко сказала що
все все робіть що хочете ДД роби що хоче
я я
буду я буду так як батько я буду
військовою будучи це помста буде Потім
це підготовка до
помсти Це просто підготовка це Ну так
страшно казать таки ж 15 років дитина
Ну жартовно служити в Україні самовідено
захищати її від будь-яких нападників
клянемося Ми майбутні Захисники
Української держави читаючи ці Рядки
військової присяги Ярослава дуже
хвилюється у жовтні вона повторить її на
урочистому зборі ліцеїстів до Дня
захисників та захисниць А нині багато
днів вона проводитиме на тренувальному
полігоні бо попереду нові навчання на
шляху до мети я хочу піти в розвитку в
Одесі
поступити і там бути роз Головне щоб
була мотивація і осмислити це чити
реально цього хочеш піти в таку
справу